(audience applauds)
- I know you're dating.
- Yes.
- You're dating,
so are you getting married
and do you wanna tell us now?
(laughs) Okay, no.
- (laughs) Girl talk!
You know what?
Not to get weird, but I think that,
also, it's important to say this,
especially to our younger fans
and younger generations of women.
I come from the Bible Belt
in Oklahoma, very proudly so,
but with that means that
you're supposed to get married,
have 2.5 kids, and live in
the white picket fence house,
and I didn't choose that for
my life, I had other goals,
and at first, I was always ashamed,
like I shouldn't tell people
that, maybe, I'm not sure
about having children or
even, maybe, getting married,
and I've had great men in my life.
I've got a great one right now.
Marriage might be the deal, it might, but
it hasn't been what's
defined me or driven me,
and, for a long time, I
was shameful about it.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, 'cause especially
from where we're from.
- Because of where we're from.
- Yeah.
- And also, thank you.
- Did people always think you were gay?
People thought I was gay forever.
- I've had some boyfriends
to make me wish I was gay, but no.
(everyone laughs)
- Me too, me too.
- No, I'm not, and as
far as people will go,
"You're not gonna have a child?"
and it's almost like, oh, selfish,
but I take care of a lot of
kids, I have many cousins.
I have godchildren I take care of,
and this is also important to say.
As an adopted child,
if I have that so desire one day,
and I wake up and I say,
"Maybe I missed the boat,"
or "Maybe I wanna do that,"
there's been so many great
examples of women who've
done that and I would just adopt a child.
There's many people out there.
(audience applauds)
- The thing about that, too,
is one, that you're picked.
My mom just got stuck with me.
(Kristin laughs)
You were picked.
- They do say you're chosen.
- They got to pick you.
- Yeah.
Yeah, that's really cool.
- It's a special feeling
and I've always known
about my adoption and
my family, they're all chemical
engineers and real tall
and they don't sing.
(Kelly laughs)
They don't sing and
they should never sing,
actually, ever.
(audience laughs)
But I don't do math, but
we learn from each other.
- That's awesome, that's so great.